act react impact it was rather difficult
not to catch this slogan when entering
the European Parliament in Strasbourg
this morning with just nine months to go
before European elections and a year
before the nomination of the new
European Commission President European
Parliament today launched its election
communications campaign saying there's a
real need for information
let's keep feeling miss first
inclusivity all-day celebration
Parliament Simon chat on spot says they
skipped an insane so la nieta Makati mia
transparent mia controller as conduct
leadership in May and the campaign will
have four phases starting with basic
explanations of the European
Parliament's new powers followed by
interactive elements on specific topics
such as the economy and jobs all the EU
in the world in Phase two starting in
February phase three will focus on the
election campaign itself phase four will
present a new type of nomination of the
Commission's president made for the
first time by the European Parliament
we're all full aware that these
elections are probably the most crucial
elections in European history because of
the difficult environment of the crisis
but we want to send a strong message to
European citizens and tell them that
they have the power they have the
possibility to reshape Europe the
information campaign will be made in 24
languages and presented in all 28 member
states the slogan act react impact
stresses that EU voters can exercise
their power does it work let's go back
outside to check among Kilcullen come
along some more columns officiel it's a
great idea
to change something in Europe and to
change something about the European
politics yeah like that one maybe a few
discussions and more action